Transcription: Samira Kwache
Relecteur: eric vautier
C’est l’histoire d’un jeune homme
de 17 ans qui a tout pour être heureux.
Une famille qui l’aime,
des amis qui l’entourent.
Plutôt bon élève, qui fait
de l’athlétisme au niveau national
et qui gagne son argent de poche
grâce à sa passion, la musique.
Je le répète, il a vraiment
tout pour être heureux.
Et comme tous les jeunes
de son âge, un jour,
il décide d’aller en soirée avec des amis.
La soirée se termine et on lui propose de
le ramener chez lui avec sa petite amie.
Il monte dans la voiture,
s’assoit sur le siège arrière droit,
commence à s’endormir,
et soudain, boum, accident !
Une voiture leur a coupé la route
et est projetée à 20 mètres.
La leur effectue
un tour et demi sur elle-même.
Complètement choqué,
il sort de la voiture, panique
et s’allonge sur le sol
en attendant les secours.
Les pompiers arrivent
et s’occupent de sa petite amie
restée dans la voiture.
Ils l’allongent sur le sol
à côté de lui et tentent de la réanimer.
A ce moment, il entend :
« Bon, on a un décès, il ne faut pas
qu’on en ait un deuxième. »
Ils le prennent en charge
et l’amènent à l’hôpital le plus proche.
Arrivé à l’hôpital, il appelle sa mère :
« Maman, on a eu un accident.
Je crois qu’elle est morte. »
Après ce coup de téléphone,
black-out total.
Il se réveille en réanimation sans
vraiment comprendre ce qui lui est arrivé.
Et il découvre sur son ventre
un gigantesque pansement
qui cache une cicatrice
boursouflée de 34 centimètres.
À ce moment-là,
il se rend compte petit à petit
de ce qui lui est arrivé,
que tout cela est bien réel,
et que sa petite amie est
malheureusement bien décédée.
Il se dit que sa vie est foutue,
qu’elle ne sera plus jamais la même,
qu’il ne sera peut-être plus capable
de marcher comme avant,
de faire du sport comme avant,
qu’il ne sera peut-être plus capable
de vivre comme avant, tout simplement,
qu’il ne sera peut-être plus
capable d’aimer comme avant,
que rien ne sera plus jamais comme avant.
La personne dont je vous parle
s’appelle Jérémy.
Je suis aujourd’hui face à vous
pour vous raconter mon histoire.
C’était le 26 mai 2012
et j’ignorais à quel point ce jour allait
changer littéralement le reste de ma vie.
Le bilan de cet accident :
deux décès, deux blessés graves.
J'étais l'un d'entre eux.
Un diagnostic vital engagé à quelques
millimètres seulement de la paraplégie
et bien évidemment,
la perte d’un être cher.
Effectivement, comme vous vous en doutez,
ce n’est pas comme ça
que j’avais prévu d’entamer ma 18e année.
Certains diront que je suis chanceux,
d’autres que je suis un rescapé.
Je leur dirai simplement que, ce jour-là,
j’ai reçu un cadeau de la vie.
Oui, je sais, ça peut paraître
complètement fou
de comparer une telle histoire
avec un cadeau.
Mais, écoutez la suite,
vous comprendrez pourquoi je vous dis ça.
Sur mon lit d’hôpital, j’avais écrit
cette phrase sur Facebook :
« ’Ce qui ne tue pas rend plus fort.”
Maintenant, j’en ai la preuve. »
J'ignorais à quel point cette phrase
allait prendre tout son sens par la suite.
Après plusieurs opérations,
je sors de l’hôpital
et commence ma rééducation tous les jours
jusqu’au moment de la rentrée scolaire.
À ce moment-là, on me propose d’effectuer
mon bac en deux ans au lieu d’une année.
Mais bien évidemment, j’ai refusé.
Je voulais être traité
comme tout le monde.
Et devinez quoi ?
J’ai réussi !
Je continue mon cursus scolaire.
Et je retrouve une vie
plus ou moins normale.
J’avais retrouvé quasiment
100 % de mes capacités physiques.
Mais, au moment où
je pensais que j’allais mieux,
je commençais à me poser
pas mal de questions.
« Mais pourquoi il m’est arrivé ça ? »
« Mais pourquoi je suis en vie
et elle est partie ? »
« Qu’est-ce que j’ai fait ?
Qu’est-ce qu’on a fait pour mériter ça ? »
« Et si on n’était pas sorti ce soir-là,
quelles seraient nos vies aujourd’hui ? »
Je rentrais petit à petit,
sans m’en rendre compte,
dans une profonde dépression.
J’avais refusé, jusque-là, tout type
d’accompagnement psychologique
mais cela devenait beaucoup
trop dur à supporter pour moi.
J'avais besoin d'aide.
J’avais besoin d’être accompagné.
Et j’ai été interné
en hôpital psychiatrique.
Je vais vous parler aussi
d’un moment crucial
qui a été l’élément déclencheur
de ma reconstruction.
C'est le jour du jugement de l'accident.
Comme si pour moi,
j’avais besoin que ce jour arrive,
qui marquait la fin de cette histoire.
En rentrant chez moi,
j’ai jeté mes somnifères
et mes antidépresseurs à la poubelle.
Je ne voulais plus jamais
en entendre parler.
Depuis ce jour-là, j’ai continué ma vie.
J’ai obtenu mon master,
j’ai voyagé dans plus de 30 pays
et j’ai commencé
la vie professionnelle que j’ai choisie.
Et c’est avec le temps et
plusieurs discussions avec des personnes
que je me suis rendu compte que
toutes les étapes que j’avais traversées
faisaient partie d’un concept
bien connu de tout le monde.
Le processus de deuil.
Choc.
Déni.
Colère.
Tristesse.
Résignation.
Acceptation.
Reconstruction.
Sept étapes qui représentent
exactement ce que j’ai vécu.
On distingue bien deux parties différentes
dans ce processus de deuil.
La partie à gauche,
tournée vers le négatif,
vers le passé, qu’on appelle le deuil.
Et la partie à droite,
tournée vers le positif, vers le futur,
qu’on appelle la résilience.
Tournée vers le positif, vers le futur.
Bien évidemment que j’ai voulu savoir
plus sur ce qu’était la résilience.
La résilience, c’est un terme
utilisé en physique
pour démontrer la capacité d’un matériau
ou d’un objet à subir un choc
et à retrouver sa forme initiale,
un peu comme un élastique.
En psychologie, Boris Cyrulnik
définit la résilience comme la capacité
à vivre, à réussir et à se développer
en dépit de l’adversité.
Ça donne envie, hein ?
Une sorte de recette magique,
un tuto, un mode d’emploi
qui va vous aider à pouvoir rebondir
après une épreuve difficile.
Vous voulez savoir ?
Bon, bien évidemment,
ce n’est pas si facile que ça.
Quand on sait qu’une personne sur deux
a vécu ou vivra un traumatisme dans sa vie
et les 50 % restants ne sont pas épargnés
par les épreuves difficiles de la vie,
il est tout à fait légitime
de se dire, de se poser la question :
« Mais que dois-je faire ?
Qu’est-ce que je peux faire, moi aussi,
pour un jour connaître cette résilience
après une épreuve difficile ? »
Je suis, vous l’avez compris,
ni un psychologue, ni un neuropsychiatre,
et encore moins un super-héros.
Et de mon humble expérience,
il y a trois choses que j’ai retenues
et que j’aimerais partager avec vous,
et qui ont été indispensables
à ma reconstruction.
Acceptez.
Aimez.
Osez.
Acceptez, aimez, osez.
Acceptez ce qui vous est arrivé.
Acceptez d’être la victime,
mais refusez de le rester.
Acceptez qu’on ne puisse pas revenir
en arrière, ni changer le passé.
Accepter, c’est changer
son regard sur les événements
et utiliser son énergie
pour aller de l’avant.
Aimez, aimez-vous,
aimez la personne que vous êtes avec
vos faiblesses, vos failles, vos douleurs.
Car les moments difficiles
ne changent en rien votre valeur.
Aimez, partagez, donnez sans compter
à ceux qui vous sont chers.
Ne restez pas seuls et
construisez-vous un cercle social solide
qui vous tire vers le haut.
Aimez la vie. Aimez chaque instant,
chaque minute, chaque seconde
et apprenez de chacune de vos expériences
pour continuer à avancer, à progresser.
Osez.
Osez affronter vos peurs !
Osez être la meilleure
version de vous-même.
Osez réaliser vos rêves.
Des rêves, j’en ai eu
et j’en ai encore plein.
Des rêves très simples,
d’autres bien plus fous.
J’avais le rêve par exemple,
un jour, de présenter un TEDx
et me voici, aujourd’hui, face à vous
pour faire de ce rêve une réalité.
La vie est composée à
20 % de ce qui nous arrive
et 80 % de comment on réagit face à ça.
Donc, neuf ans plus tard, j’aimerais dire
quelque chose à ce petit Jérémy.
Mais pas seulement.
Je m’adresse aussi à toi, à vous.
À toutes les personnes qui ont vécu
ou qui vivront un jour un traumatisme.
Non, votre vie n'est pas foutue.
Oui, vous pouvez surmonter cette épreuve.
Et oui, vous en sortirez
peut-être même plus forts
parce que ce qui ne vous tue pas
vous rend plus fort.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)